and I think that we're at that point of
like a crisis moment as humanity is like
having the mirror turned on itself so
like we've built all these amazing
technologies and the Industrial
Revolution and civilization and all
these things that we think are the
ascent you know but then when we start
to get closer and closer to the peak of
that we look around and we're like oh my
gosh we're interconnected with all
things and we need to have respect for
our environment you know we need to stop
like we need to have appropriate
technologies that work with the whole so
that's part of what I feel like my work
in this world is is to work on my own
self my own consciousness in order to
get to the point where I can offer this
gift of awareness and seem that we're
all interconnected boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don Sakia we are at consciousness
hackings a week in future summit we are
now going to be talking to Ian Michael
hey bear hello hello thank you so much
for coming on the show really appreciate
whether it's good to see you again good
to see you again - yeah it's been a
while there's been a lot of leveling up
in the meanwhile are so excited to talk
in Michael let's start with who you are
and what you represent sounds good well
I typically identify as being a human
being which is a really you know
interesting concept and experience and I
grew up in the middle of Alaska in this
lifetime and so deep in my veins and in
my psyche are wild places and I've
always been an explorer of the
wilderness whether it's the wilderness
that is the natural world or the
wilderness that's inside of us and that
wilderness has the whole possible
spectrum of experiences beauty
challenges and that's really who I am
I'm an explorer of of all of that and
I'm a creator I grew up the son of a
carpenter used to build custom homes
that were you know appropriate to
northern climates and energy of
and ecologically designed and all of
that and as I got into my teenage years
I had the dawning realization that not
all of humanity has the same experience
as me and that there was a lot of
suffering in the world you know and
including in my own family and living in
the north is not an easy thing but I
realized that a lot of people throughout
the world are really disconnected from
themselves and from the natural world so
my early intentions for this life were
to move to the jungle in Central America
and try to live inside of an eco
community didn't quite end up working
out that way and life has had a
different circuitous path to that but I
really have always had this desire to
live on the land live in community and
just live a good healing life like a
very simple good healing life and that
has manifest as different ways that I've
served humanity through retreat centers
or getting a masters in counseling
psychology and serving many different
diverse populations and serving Esalen
Institute the birthplace of the human
potential movement and just continuing
to track and listen to who are the
people that I want to be aligned with
what are the organizations that really
called me and so I would say that's kind
of in summary what who and what I'm up
to all the way from having the the wild
roots in Alaska all the way to the
identification has a human being yeah
and then and then just the weirdness of
that experience the beauty of that
experience and then all the way through
figuring out how to you feel like
there's some sort of a strange
disconnection of humans from source yeah
teach us more about this yeah for sure I
think that it first starts with a
disconnection from ourselves and a
disconnection from others and the disc
from the natural world and our essential
nature as life as you know as part of
this ongoing process of DNA and
adaptation and evolution is something
that our ego forgets that were part of a
process we identify with these like
moments in time how we fit into society
how we fit into our environment and so
we get really can you know kind of we
build up this whole concept of who we
are and in reality that is gone in a
moment and so you know I I was just
describing this experience earlier at
the conference we were doing an exercise
to talk about a moment of awe so there
was this woman Cassandra Vuitton I've
worked with her at the Institute of
noetic Sciences she was sharing how
they're the founder of Institute of
noetic Sciences Edgar Mitchell was the
sixth man to walk on the moon and when
he was coming back from walking on the
moon he was looking outside the capsule
and he saw the Sun and the earth and
realized that it's all one unity he had
a moment of Satori and so Satori yeah
teach us about that question yeah Satori
was basically a term that is used to
describe a moment of recognizing the
unity of all things so he was looking
down to the earth and he said oh my gosh
all human experience is contained on
this on this ball as far as we know you
know and that all life is contained on
this part the ball as far as we know and
there's no divisions of countries or
species or any of it it's all actually
one unity of consciousness that was what
he experienced and so after she gave
this prompt I was sharing with a
colleague guy Martin sharp he's got a
retreat center called synthesis they do
psychedelic work in the Netherlands and
he's a partner on this project that I'll
get into more about holos and so we were
paired up and I was describing to him a
moment of awe and when I was 19 years
old I climbed the tallest mountain in
North America Denali in the middle of
Alaska and it's actually the tallest
mountain terrestrial mountain in the
world from base to summit it goes from
2,000 feet to 20,000 feet so we climbed
over the course of 22 days to the summit
of this mountain from the lake to the
top of the mountain and about 18 days
through it was the dawn of my 20th
birthday we were hiking up a ridge it
was I was out about 17,000 feet so
pretty tall up on this mountain and I
was looking out towards the northern
horizon and the Sun hit the horizon and
then and then came back up and there was
this moment of profound stillness and in
stillness we have an opportunity to see
things from a new vantage point possibly
a more clear vantage point and I could
feel myself my sense of attention and
awareness merge into the whole earth
merge into the Sun and I could feel the
way that the earth was tilted towards
the Sun in the summer and tilted away
from the Sun in the winter and the way
that each day is a spinning of that
cycle so like I got to experience
through my mind and through my awareness
like merging into our solar system and
the reason I share this is I think that
it's analogous to to the ascent of any
man and ego where we think that or any
woman and ego where we think we're like
or even civilization we think we're like
climbing the mountain we're like getting
to the peak of some experience and then
when we we start getting closer to that
peak we realize that actually like we
are consciousness and all things are
conscious so like part of my experience
and my belief is that all things
including mountains are actually
conscious all life is conscious the
universe is aware it's a self-aware
universe and I can't remember what the
prompt was that that initiated that
story with you but I think it's an
important like analogy for just the the
folly of our experience as human beings
and what we're doing it's like we try to
build all these things and then we end
up coming to the realization and I think
that we're at that point of like a
crisis moment as humanity is like having
the mirror turned on itself so like
we've built all these amazing
technologies in the Industrial
Revolution and civilization and all the
things that we think are the assent you
know but then when we start to get
closer and closer to the peak of that we
look around and we're like oh my gosh
we're interconnected with all things and
we need to have respect for our
environment you know we need to stop
like we need to have appropriate
technologies that work with the whole so
that's part of what I feel like my work
in this world is is to work on my own
self my own consciousness in order to
get to the point where I can offer this
gift of awareness and seen that we're
all interconnected yeah yeah yes such a
good one okay yeah the the prompt being
that we disconnect from the source and
you give us this really profound
illustration of how we have these
moments of deep connection Edgar
Mitchell yeah yeah from Nordic Sciences
mhm
Wow yeah what a profound one and then
also yours on Denali these types of
experiences there's no going back to the
old mental maps exactly it's the
upgrades and they're gorgeous upgrades
and I hopefully we can provide more
experiences like that humans and when
humans are born in Metropolis is that
don't have the cosmic views of the
cosmos or that barely have breathing
space in parks and nature's and stuff
it's just like feel is very
disconnecting at times yeah and so
embedded in the economic machine and so
distant from spiritual practices yeah so
we have a lot of the physical 3d world
to build in ways that get us there
faster to this reconnection back to the
unity okay so then okay so then walk us
through so you gave us that example of
the disconfirm source now you're
connecting to your own divinity your own
this this level of consciousness that
you that you that you are striving to
kind of upgrade yourself to be able to
then bring forth better tools and
awareness just for other people right
yeah yeah absolutely and then what is
what has been kind of those milestones
for you in terms of where you're like ah
ha ah ha ha
then what are the things that you've
been building yeah absolutely thanks for
asking I think those aha moments have
kind of come through a lot of different
modalities so they it could have been as
simple as being seven years old and
running down a trail through a birch
forest and like feeling a sense of
elation and awe and beauty and wonder
and kind of dissolving into the forest
in a sense you know and then there's
been all these different moments that
have helped weave a tapestry and
understanding of how the consciousness
within me can recognize the
consciousness beyond itself as actually
one in the same and so psychedelics
certainly were a big part of that
journey in my teenage years and and then
I reached a point where they served
their purpose for that time and so the
majority or all of my 20s were more in
service to family meditation gardening
building homes like very like more
earth-based things but the internal
contemplative practice continued mostly
through meditation and so I had a
teacher in India still do and and and I
had many experiences with them that were
very psychedelic experiences you know
we're fully transcendent of the world of
form and so I recognize that there's a
lot of pathways you know to getting to
the same destination it's like all
weaving back to two source as you're
saying and so most recently I spent a
number of years at Esalen and that kind
of reopened me to the world of the human
potential movement psychedelics the
teachings of all of the you know like
luminaries of the 60s and 70s and and as
I finished my time up and my service up
at Esalen I started to look at okay I
experienced a template of how we can
live and how we can learn and how we can
grow together there and how can I bring
that into the world how can I bring what
I
learned from childhood about right way
of living and what I learned from Esalen
and Chena Hot Springs how can I bring
that into the world so that has led me
to this concept of holos and it's a bit
of a tip of the hat to Stan Grof so Stan
Grof had lived at Esalen at one point
and was considered one of the cofounders
of transpersonal psychology and he
developed a technique called holotropic
breathwork which was basically a means
to to transcendence healing and and he
developed a whole map of the inner
landscape of what people would
experience through holotropic breathwork
and i think for him it was it was
partially a means to going into these
transpersonal states that was legal you
know it was like a point when the LSD
research that he had been doing very
legally in the Czech Republic wasn't
allowed in the US and he developed this
this idea of the holotropic paradigm and
that was basically like returning to
wholeness it was like means for moving
to wholeness
so holos represents wholeness and that's
a journey that each of us takes
individually and that we're taking as a
society and that we're realizing our
wholeness with ecological realities of
this globe No
okay okay so it makes more sense so then
the experiences that can kind of lead us
to the feelings of wholeness and can be
like you said as simple as being walking
down the path and seeing becoming one
with the forest dissolving into it and
then taking us all the way up to the
work at Esalen and being around the
thoughts of the luminaries of the past
that have built up some of the the the
updates that we've had with our
awareness shifts you then find that
holos wholeness and what exactly is
holos building yeah you know wholeness
is building experiences and then
ultimately centers that honor the power
of plant medicines
so specifically psilocybin and
Pedro in ayahuasca and those being kind
of a band of plants that have been
helping humanity especially the
indigenous people of North and South
America for thousands of years and we
believe that those are generally
accessible to the public and that
they're also getting a lot of attention
for being powerful healing modalities
for things like depression anxiety PTSD
working with end-of-life issues
so we're basically a lie that we're
using these allies these plant allies as
a means to helping people return to what
actually is which is that we are already
whole and that our relationship with the
earth is what is meeting really some
some work as a species and so we believe
in working with these allies through
experiences and through centers to show
people a new template for how to be and
how to live just thinking about the
thousands of years of use of psilocybin
and San Pedro and I waskind what it's
actually been able to to do for for
millions of people and and now being in
the mainstream culture is there a wave
now to get through the taboo and to get
to this the the utmost signal with these
centers that are that are being built
you listed some you know synthesis also
you've just done a lot of work with
transformational retreat centered design
and development so you're extremely
familiar with these processes so is the
is the idea then um physical locations
that people then come to those locations
and then go through multi-day long
processes exactly nutritional as well as
body movement as well as exactly
innocent okay
teach us about what it looks like yeah
sounds good so one thing that we're
recognizing in the field of psychedelic
medicine is that there's a lot of need
for more preparation
and for integration so it's not just
about the psychedelic experiences and so
the intention is that the experiences
will be held within a bigger context of
a you know a multi-day probably at least
a week experience where people do have a
holistic approach to healing where
there's good food and you learn about
personal practices and develop your own
personal practices for taking whatever
gifts you receive from the plants into
your day to day life through meditation
embodiment practices whatever those
things may be yeah it's it's very much
like if we're to take this word holos
and and really work with it in our own
selves and lives it has a lot to teach
you know like just the concept of
wholeness it's like you're talking about
like the more mainstream adoption I
think that if we look towards the future
at the same time we need to look towards
the past and that's how it grounds it so
in the past these traditions were really
held with a lot of reverence in
indigenous cultures within the context
of community and so that's a big piece
of what those traditions have to offer
the future is like that is a beautiful
template and there's specific ways to
honor these medicines that if we look
back at the past of what really worked
we can probably build a template for the
future that is also going to work and be
more accessible and the template that
you're talking about here of the past as
well how does the template of the past
interplay with modernity mm-hmm with the
information technology agent so yeah
that's an ongoing conversation you know
it's like this moment is having is an
integration of the past and the future
and so this moment it's like how do
these plants and states of consciousness
relate to this present moment and what
humans are doing and what I found is
that you know there's an intelligence in
the plants themselves that is
interacting with the present moment and
really looking at it you know like as an
actual and
do you like hey what do you what are you
humans up to and like we have something
to teach you and maybe you have
something to teach us and there's like
actually a dialogue going on like
there's an intelligence coming through
humans to and through our capacity to
build technology and AI and and other
you know arv are like there's something
in all of that that is actually
evolutionarily useful otherwise it
wouldn't be occurring so like instead of
having a dogmatism around like here's
nature here's man here's technology I
have a real curiosity about how are all
of those things part of a conversation
that's happening and how can they learn
from each other whoa
okay so then there there is a something
that's embedded deeper in the
consciousness of the cosmos that is at
play between technology plants and
humans and and our that that interplay
to actually double click into it and
dissect it and figure it out rather than
maybe just in many ways sometimes it
feels like the distractions away from
what's actually important to unpack
about it what now how do we get deeper
into what plants are telling so by doing
things like holos and going out so we
need to send the AI ethicists and
programmers to almost - is that kind of
a way to do the feedback loop with
technology and play medicine yeah that's
definitely one possible way and I think
a lot of like I think a lot of the
artists musicians creatives are also
really weaving the lessons of plant
medicine and psychedelics into their
creations and so that's another way that
that dialogue is happening but yeah I
have sat in medicine circles with people
that are you know pretty far on the AI
side like working in a
and the best you know the best case
scenario that I can see is that we embed
into some of these artificial
intelligences also ancient intelligence
you know there's another kind of AI
there's ancient intelligence and there's
artificial intelligence and so hopefully
you know through care and consideration
some of that ancient intelligence and
knowledge will get embedded into our
technologies I was just using this
analogy yesterday or earlier today of
like okay so let's just say that science
tells us the universe of form is
thirteen to fourteen billion years old
mushrooms are like 2.5 billion years old
there's rock formations that human
beings can see that are around a billion
years old so if you just were to like
look at it from the from the standpoint
of infinity you could kind of look at 13
billion years as not that long you could
look down at it and say okay here's 13
billion years there's a lot of
intelligence in the physics of
everything that was created during that
time there's a lot of intelligence in
the 2.5 billion years that mushrooms and
fungus have been around there's a lot of
intelligence in the in the rocks and
then human beings it's like a tiny
little blip in in all of that 13 billion
years so I would hope that like we can
have enough reverence for the universe
to recognize that there's there's a
weaving and there's an intelligence that
we have to learn from in what created us
and what the you know so and what the
plants have to teach what the fungus
have to teach yeah that's a real big
history perspective on what's happening
we love big history and to view add to
view it in I love how you added
sometimes we look at just 13.8 billion
and then we go oh that's everything but
then you went infinity and one of
there's infinity and you look at 13.8
billion then that looks small right and
that's a great that's a that's a great
way to add them the big history scale so
then yeah you look at the I didn't even
know that that
so so fun fungus in general is 3.5
billion years old Daniel yeah damn Wow
yeah it is if what for some for some
reason just is that older than trees
it's older than yeah yeah Wow so that's
some old stuff yeah and so you know it
like there was a person in our session
earlier that was talking about a really
strong psilocybin journey that they went
on and they came to the point of
actually having an interaction with the
psilocybin and the spirit of the fungus
or the consciousness of the of the fungi
apart from himself and so like just to
have that that idea or that awareness
that like human beings like you and I
are having a conversation well what
would it be like for you to have a
conversation with entity that has been
around for 2.5 billion years and has
been like spreading its mycelium and
watching this whole thing happened I had
a conversation like that with the Grand
Canyon two years ago so I was kayaking
down the Grand Canyon recognizing that
these rocks that I was looking at were
almost a billion years old so I started
like having this conversation with what
have you seen seen you know but that's
like pretty impressive yeah you know and
then it's like our whole folly of oh
yeah we're creating AI and our fears
around that or some people's fears
around that or climate change or all
these things like they are you know they
are real especially like climate change
you know it's like that is causing the
sixth mass extinction or it's one of the
cause causal factors of the sixth great
mass extinction of this planet but you
know in the grander scheme of things if
you're a rock or a fungus and you're
watching all this you're kind of like
huh you really think you're that
important you know and so it's good to
put things in perspective and and the
mind has the capacity to hold all of
those potentialities or stories I mean
ultimately they're kind of stories yeah
and so the hefty dose of humility mm-hmm
that is administered through thinking
like this and also
yeah yeah and on also the that there's
so much to get into conversation with
something as ancient ancient
intelligence mm-hmm
AI embedding ancient intelligence into
artificial intelligence embedding AI and
AI has I love it love it yeah it's it's
excellent it's excellent and even the
idea of something being artificial you
know it's like what does that definition
actually mean you know like to another
species they've been saying it's not a
good yeah it's probably not the right
term turnbull you'll evolve out of that
will evolve out of the term I wonder
what yeah super intelligence has been
another common one but super
intelligence meaning not narrow
intelligence so that's a general
intelligence that's even able to self
replicate itself and do additive
manufacturing and all other kinds of
crazy things but on I I do much prefer
something like us like a super
intelligence I'm glad that you that you
mentioned that your artificial yeah but
then you know just to like weave it all
the way back it's like we have the
capacity to under understand all these
things and you know the mind can can
look at all the different aspects of
reality and create culture and and then
for me I end up coming back to like I'm
in a body you know Here I am
consciousness in a body consciousness
pervading a body and what does my body
want you know my body wants some really
basic things like to be comforted and to
have good healthy food and water and air
and so that's a big piece of the holos
narrative but also of just like the
human experience what does it mean to be
a whole human you know and so I think
we've come we've we've gotten kind of
separated from that as
and it doesn't mean that we can't embed
holistic ways of living into cities but
for me personally it's really about a
deep dialogue with the natural world so
yeah so holo centers will be embedded in
nature just to remind people of that
interdependence and like perfect harmony
that we can live with in nature on a
night I'm gonna scale of what's been
passed down to us by our ancestors up
until our little twenty-five or fifty
year blips of time let's say and
compared to what maybe has been passed
down through fungus or through other
yeah yeah just yeah what carry what
carries more intelligence you know in
its vehicle us or those systems and so
it's always an interesting thing to
contemplate holes is coming in a very
timely manner are we able to at all
approximate when there's there will be a
center available and where that sphere
will start okay we'll start prototyping
experiences at the beginning twenty or
twenty nine exiting of 2020 in in North
Central South America yeah we're doing
the research right now on all the local
legal jurisdictions and so initially
it'll be experiences and then okay the
center itself will likely be in Costa
Rica first okay we're waiting for the
North America and Canadian policies to
catch up with an ancient culture yeah
yeah yeah there's quick quick thought on
this what are your thoughts about the
reason why the ancient intelligences of
plant medicines were banned was due to
their their catalyzing of feelings of
unity which would sacrifice the economic
no yeah absolutely I mean there's like
so many trails to go down there one I
think it's the suppression of the
feminine and like the hyper masculine
culture that has basically said like the
natural world is there for us to
dominate and when there's plants talking
to you or talking to a culture
indigenous culture saying hey you're
part of everything it's not a really
popular way of seeing or being when
you're in a system that needs to
dominate so I think that's like the
primary unconscious thing that's
happening and then there's the next
layer which is here are like religions
or practices that the indigenous people
were doing and if we can take away their
culture and their practices and and make
that wrong then we have the upper hand
you know and so there is the religious
freedoms Act so there's things like the
you know the Native American church they
can that can work with peyote or San
Pedro or there's the UDV or there's you
know there's there's practices where you
can work with ayahuasca in the u.s.
within the religious freedoms Act so
that's like one safeguard that these
plants have but for a long time I think
that was a big piece of the suppression
is that it's about culture and
suppression of the feminine and then
beyond that it's like if there's
substances that are legal that we can
tax and we can get people hooked on and
that's a really great formula or if
there's substances that we can make
illegal and we can get people hooked on
them and then send them to jail because
we're trying to take a certain
population and keep them out of the
power structure those are really good
means to controlling a society so you've
got alcohol highly addictive tobacco
highly addictive and taxable and so
that's a really good reason why a
government might want to keep that those
two industries really strong and then
you've got things like heroin or cocaine
and as a government you might want to
keep those strong so that you can choose
populations that you want to keep out of
society and send them to jail whereas so
I mean I'm giving you kind of a broad I
love it keep going and then you've got
psychedelics which which are actually
like a liberation of the psyche and
aren't addictive in the same ways and so
you know like those are the ones that
you want to put into Schedule one say
that they have no healing value
and and there you have it because it
breaks down the system of your control
well yeah so whatever is yeah in aim to
control has has had a grip on on
propagating the economic machineries of
the structures that currently exist and
suppressing the healing properties the
unity properties of things like
psychedelics and and so much more it's
always fascinating to me thinking of
what a simulation would look like if we
grew up in a matriarchy and just seeing
feeling what would be some of the great
characteristics what would be some of
the ones that aren't so great and well
how would we take the great ones how
could we implement them into what we
currently have not just all different
types of things like that just it's kind
of more it's such a deep curiosity of
mine and I end up bringing it back to
myself and like working on you know
really coming to terms with the
masculine and feminine within me and
having them in some form of harmony and
and unity that's the end of like a first
step and then maybe I'll have something
to say and contribute to the larger
conversation yes yes yes um two quick
questions you Michael two quick
questions
um are we in a simulation I don't have
an answer to that yeah I mean largely
like yes in the sense that everything
that we're experiencing is filtered
through a very very small bandwidth of
reality and so in the sense of a
simulation being just a small band of of
what we can experience that's actually
to some extent manipulated by our senses
and by our memories and by what we're
expecting to see then we're a simulation
that we're creating you know we're in a
simulation that we're creating to a
large extent with the way that our mind
is wired yeah I've been having some
really fascinating thought processes and
conversations though around what is
happening with ARV
and like more immersive experiences that
are created by technology and by man
that even likes simulate natural
experiences in nature and how that has
therapeutic benefits actually for
relaxation and all these things and at
the same time we're moving pretty far
into the like the movie The Matrix where
you're just hooking yourself up and and
living in a simulation so I don't
necessarily have all the answers to that
but I have I have glimmers of the
ultimate reality and truth so I don't
take too much of this you know I take it
all at face value yeah in the last
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world well the first thing
that came to mind was my kids you know
and I think that there's a way that we
see as parents our own innocence within
our kids and and like our own beauty and
creativity and and so I think the most
beautiful thing in the world is probably
creativity and innocence it's like going
back to that seed moment that the
universe started expanding and things
moved into greater complexity it's like
whatever that moment of conception was
that the sperm and egg come together or
you know in other species you know when
those when that moment of creation
happens I think that that's the most
beautiful thing and you can see it in a
child's eyes with the like twinkle and
excitement it's like it's that same
moment of creation that is in a flower
that is blossoming and yeah I would say
that's the most beautiful thing this has
have been such a wonderful conversation
yeah thanks in this view again yeah
thank you so much for coming on the show
yeah brother this was a pleasure yeah
thank you
what's the link for holos holos global
holo stock global everyone check out the
link in the bio to that also check out
the rest of Ian Michaels links in the
bio
and also support the organization's the
entrepreneurs the artists around the
world that you believe in conscious
acting's links are below support them
also simulations links are below support
us and have more conversations around
the world with our friends our families
our co-workers people online on social
media about playing medicines about
these retreat center designs and
development and this unity how we can
get there most effectively together and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon
boom that was a blast really good I'm
glad you had a good time I had a great
time you were such a pleasure